Pope is portraying archie coleman in the
hit Netflix show Hollywood Archie is an
openly gay black man trying to make it
as a screenwriter in the 1940s he needs
[Music]
one
he doesn't already know I never met
anybody person I mailed in my squid he
called me on the telephone I told him
Godley mr. Samuels I'm just over the
moon you liked my script and Jimmy Pope
joins us now from Florida Jeremy good
morning and happy birthday here
yesterday was the big day so Hollywood
is a really interesting premise and I
don't know if people could get it from
that clip but the idea is that Archie is
an openly gay black screenwriter in the
1940s only none of the prejudice and
bias and obstacles that we know existed
then exists in his path so with that
kind of alternative history how did you
prepare for it coming from well here and
now yeah it felt very timely I mean Ryan
presented the idea to me
you know I think our show simply just
asked the questions of you know what if
we had given equal opportunities
regardless of you know the color of your
skin or how do you identify and that
message is so powerful so to see
something like that on a TV you know
form whether it be a fantasy it still
gives people a tangible idea of how
powerful that message is of equality and
how we today in 2020 still have some
room to go was it enjoyable to go back
and imagine what might have been or was
it sad it was enjoyable for me because I
knew the the representation the
visibility that it was going to show and
give to people would be hopeful and you
know oddly enough pressure came out
during the pandemic so everyone was able
to binge watch it but also it just makes
you think you know how what type of art
do I want to make how can I be a better
ally in the community and make sure that
this world that we want to create of
equal opportunity can become something
tangible want something real for us now
yeah yeah no I asked about the sadness
because we know for so many real-life
screenwriters in that era it wasn't an
easy path I'm curious as you look back
and inhabited the role if there are
aspects of Archie that you relate to you
from your vantage point today
absolutely I think for me where I just
connected with Archie is just you know
often wondering if there's space in a
room for me in the entertainment
industry a lot of times there is usually
one person of color that can be
successful at a time so you know just
Archie has to face a lot of hardships
and is trying to break the mold trying
to be the first because he knows that by
him doing that it's bigger than just an
Archie success or in my case a Jeremy
success but it's offering visibility for
so many artists and people that come
from that same narrative so they often
know by seeing things like that by
having an example like that that they
are wanted respected that there is room
for them at the table and I think that
message is so so powerful Jeremy it's
Vlad I loved you as Eddie Kendricks I
love you as Archie in Hollywood you say
you pick projects to work on that you
believe are for the greater good so how
did Archie fit into that Archie again
you know it's just the the narrative of
the what if and me coming from a place
where I was working in theater but you
know have dreams of doing so many things
but TV and film was a goal of mine so in
comes Ryan Murphy with this show that is
rewriting history and giving you know me
me but black artists and black writers
an opportunity and a place at the table
so I just I just know that it's
incredibly special and the messages I've
received from people that have felt
moved from the show it's just incredible
you know it's it's a it's an incredible
journey that I've been on I'm learning
so much about myself but I know that
we're changing the world and the stories
I've been a part of have changed so many
people's lives I just have one more
quick question as we're getting pushed
off into break but your total store
about your mom passing out at your very
first Broadway performance and when she
woke up she said yeah hello I'm not
leaving how did she react to you I saw
you on TV MA she didn't pass out
which is great and you know it she's
just so proud all about my family here
in Florida I'm with them this week
they're just so powerful prouder over
the moon and she threw a zoom party for
me cuz I didn't get to have a proper
premiere for my TV debut and all of my
friends and family were on this zoom and
it was really really special mom I love
her I love all my family that support
ani it's just it's just been a crazy
journey for it's all been fun pushing
all right keep on pushing sherry poop
thank you very much Hollywood is
streaming on Netflix thank you right now